this is gonna be a character-building
day for me today I don't I don't think
so Nina Oh freezing
[Music]
go on innovating welcome to the - had a
really rough night last night
lots of vomiting and other not so nice
stuff it was scary
scary wasn't it wasn't great my throat's
a little rough from I'll be acid anyway
maybe I had food poisoning we'll see but
we are back at it we've got the army of
kids behind this we are going to get
some food and then explore Key West
Florida
you're not vlogging today Ritchie he is
[ __ ] your login to day one that's
nice I like it
[Music]
[Music]
what's for breakfast Wow
I'm going cereal without milk so don't
upset my stomach
there's Nina's breakfast you know
there's a hunter girl
Nina's back for round two what'd you get
ash brown don't mess with Nina and her
hash browns
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is gonna be a character-building
day for me today got fever but time to
show some grit and I am the tour guide
for everybody so they're counting on me
to deliver so we're gonna go have some
fun EQs
the kids decided they want to have ice
cream already and the other parents went
alone so we're here at the ice q story
what flavor you're gonna get hatin Milky
Way all right how is it good thumbs up
Ritchie nice yummy it was a good so next
we're gonna hit off mallory square which
is the big shopping tourists lively
neighborhood last time I came here it
was pretty fun so hopefully with the
kids it'll be even more fun I always
plan one of our stops around the
Starbucks if it's in the city because
Nina likes her coffee and I do too but
the way my stomach's going right now
thinking on a pass but we're gonna get
something yummy for the wife you got a
hot drink yeah it's hot sorry
alright next we're gonna have some key
lime pie if you guys are fan of the show
the Prophet he made an investment into a
company here in Key West so we're gonna
go in they're supposed to have great key
lime pie I'll give it a shot see if you
like it how is it yeah how is it
[Music]
okay next up we are going to rent some
golf carts and tour around the city hit
up a beach get some more food and
continue our adventure
found it pirate rentals scooter cars and
bikes the boys are ready this is our
part time the hit to the beach and have
some fun I don't I don't think so Nina
how is anything called
you're gonna go swimming Oh freezing
they jump in
[Music]
apparently the beach passed out not
feeling that great but okay get fun
close the best part
Richards you went in the cold water you
feel it
your face is cold on my on my arm we're
gonna go next
back on the Gulf cuts we're doing it for
two hours and the listicle back don't go
back and you excited to go back your
side exciting accompany kids can't
tomorrow
[Music]
already we're not ready
[Music]
all right you made it in next stop we're
gonna go to one of the most famous
sandwich shops on the island hell yeah
Bo's fish wagon and nobody's really
hungry especially me but we're gonna all
share a sandwich or two because it's a
local tradition and you gotta check it
[Music]
[Applause]
you decided to get a beer orange to
olivine safaris the polarization stories
four o'clock
I didn't think I'd lose weight on this
cruise but right now here it is the
famous grouper sandwich with Key Lime
mayonnaise I was in the unit so it
became fine Haydn's eating the onion
rings yummy
yeah
[Music]
so Nina likes always trying new food and
so every place we go to
she's polishing off her yeah
legendary deliver with real I mean
[Music]
all right lunch is done got a kickback
the go-carts and then head back to the
cruise
[Music]
so the initial idea of going on a trip
with all this family was that you know
we could isolate parents not have so
many kids but the kids are wanting to go
back to the cruise ship and so Nina Nina
volunteered us to take two adults and
four kids all the way back
[Music]